welcome to the last talk of the day
which will be impressive in person
uh it's a it's a real pleasure to
introduce ralph raff is a professor from
the university of colorado he's done a
lot of like very interesting
work in a diverse set of areas from
information elicitation uh
peer prediction all the way to dynamical
systems in tears theory
and although his work is very diverse
it's also
universally very interesting so whatever
he'll talk about it will be a lot of fun
okay rough please
wow okay thanks
um
yeah so
today's talk is about um forecasting
competitions uh it's joint work with bo
wagoner and two of our students robert
and anish
and
um
so forecasting competitions i mean this
somewhat broadly so in particular
all machine learning competition well
not all but many machine learning
competitions on kaggle for example
um
but i think it's better
and you'll see why it's better to think
maybe more about human scale forecasting
competitions like good judgment
and the hybrid forecasting and so on
um so here's here's kind of the setup
and
um
you know like tim said we've this is
probably like the 10th talk on
forecasting in the workshop or something
but just to fix ideas so
i'll remind you of the general settings
so we have
let's say n forecasters
and m events
and
in each event
a forecaster will furnish some
probability say probability of rain
and um given all this information so
every forecaster submits their
predictions for all the events
we eventually learn the outcomes
so we see we see what happens and you
know a competition
is really just a mechanism that converts
all of this information to a winner
and so we're interested in
designing that that competition
mechanism right so how should we do this
well
i'll tell you what basically all
forecasting competition mechanisms do
is something that we call in this paper
the simple max mechanism where you take
um each of these predictions
um so 25 chance of rain and rain you you
take each of these pairs prediction
outcome you score them in some way
using like a proper scoring rule and you
sum up the scores for each agent for
each forecaster what was their score at
the end of the competition and they just
picked the one with the highest score
right so
fair enough um
it's quite sensible especially if you
use a proper scoring rule it feels like
the right thing to do but actually has
strange incentive problems and that's
kind of the
starting point for this work
um so here's a very simple example we
have three forecasters
and one outcome so we're trying to
predict just the probability of rain
tomorrow
and one forecaster is completely correct
so they know that there's a 50 chance of
rain but they also know that there are
these two other bozos
who like
one who thinks it's very unlikely and
one who thinks is very likely and the
problem is
yeah they'll never win
right so they also know that they have
no chance of winning because if it
doesn't rain then this bozo looks like a
genius and if it does rain then this one
does
so deterministically no matter what
happens they know they're going to lose
so what do they do well
they're going to deviate
to
you know either slightly less than 10 or
slightly more than 90 now they at least
have a one-half chance of winning
and the issue here is that
the proper scoring rule literature it's
it's designed around a slightly
different
you know incentive structure where
you're trying to maximize your expected
score so we're thinking of these as
payments but that's not what this agent
is trying to do they're trying to
maximize their chance of winning the
competition
and
those incentives don't align very well
especially when the number of events is
short
um so there aren't that many events and
you might ask okay is this
like most of these competitions are not
on one event so is this a real problem
it turns out it is a real problem
um there's this very interesting uh blog
post by andrew landgraf who won the
2017
kaggle march mania competition which is
a march madness thing and he details how
he did it
and it's quite fascinating like so like
so when i found this figure to be honest
i was like oh thank god this is going to
make this slide for my talk so easy
because
look in in his description he's
he's modeling basketball games but he's
also modeling what other people are
going to do and then computing a best
response
he's literally like
yeah he's putting all this effort into
finding a best response and
it's so clear that that's different than
you know whatever this model number one
might have predicted right it matters a
little bit how
the competition is selecting winners
are people giving probabilistic
forecasts for example
yeah so we'll say that yeah so in this
competition and we're giving
probabilistic forecasts
um i think you use the log loss which is
actually an interesting point
that you might get to at the end is that
what you were asking well
i mean there's an exponentially sized
state space of who wins you know there's
a large number of brackets that could
win
and so what was the i guess i want to
know what the
one
oh yeah yeah so i'll get to that in the
next slide actually
um i think it's like effectively you
could think about about 2 000 binary
outcomes
just like equivalent to
the outcome complexity is that is that
what you mean i'll wait for more details
yeah i have never completed a forecast
competition so i don't know how this is
oh i'm sorry
what does it mean that the truth is that
50 percent
i assume the truth is that people go out
he trains or it doesn't rain so
uh
the competition
waits to learn from you in number for a
day somehow it asks you
it will rain with five four uh
right so is there a probability are
these events actually drawn from some
distribution what is
what is it all i'm trying to understand
in the competition when someone wants
understanding that for past there is a
good one we take a deterministic action
like a bandit i learned that
this forecaster for the uh
profit
today we will have rain uh
it is one zero or like fifty percent i i
think the question is what does it mean
that fifty percent is right now
like what does it mean for the
probability to be the right number
either it's going to rain or not
so uh
is it likely to be many times you know
he has to be correct
at the time or
yeah so i was anticipating a lot of
objections but not this one
it's a very good point when it gets like
deep into the philosophy of probability
um at a technical level i don't think it
will matter too much but it's been a
while since i thought about it
again i don't know how it is in the
competition so let's just imagine for
now there is some true probability
we don't have access to it um and as a
competitor i should submit a probability
notification yeah oh okay that is a
question yeah yes oh but right so this
is what you submit
right right so you're submitting
probably that's the thing but the truth
now i submit 50 percent the the
organizer would say okay the truth was
that it rains
so
you earn 0.5 or the truth is that the
probability the probability
twenty percent yeah so the truth all you
all you learn is whether it mean or not
thank you
yeah so you never you never observe the
true probability
right
yeah
yeah and so mapping this to typical
cargo competition m would be the number
of data points right yeah would you say
that this like when m is large
a still problem or lesser problem it's a
lesser problem when m is large um
and that we'll be focusing a lot on how
they emits so we'll see we'll we'll
basically be trying to push this into a
regime where
good things happen even for a smaller
hand so it's like a little bit more
chaos right now yeah smaller
central limit theorem kind of right
yeah exactly if there's very very good
concentration in all the scores then
it's not going to be a big problem
okay
so right so
um
so sure enough this is a problem that
does show up in in some sense and like
what what really is the problem with the
misalignment of incentives
one i say like the first order thing is
it's not even clear whether we're
picking the best forecaster
like
andrew landgraf seems really good at
these things
and you know maybe the model for number
one was pretty different but maybe he
won the competition because he was
really good at realizing that he needed
to best respond and carrying that out
so
it's not even clear and by best
forecaster i mean the forecaster's
beliefs
are closest to the true probabilities
regardless of what they report and you
know whether or not there is a true
probabilities is another question
um it's also a waste after problem so if
you think about
um
you know say especially this is kind of
related to the third one um if you're
trying to use these
actual forecasts for aggregation down
the line or something you'd like them to
be as good as possible
and you're kind of wasting
on the forecaster's effort because
they're strategizing instead of just you
know instead of trying to improve model
one
andrew has to spend his time on you know
two and three also so that's effort that
could have gone into you know studying
basketball more or something i don't
know
how to do these things
okay so we'd like to solve this problem
in some way
um
any questions so far on like the issue
well it does seem also that like you
know the problem is that the winner take
all mechanism
yeah
or something like this
that is a very interesting comment which
we'll see you later um
but yeah the fact that you're you're
insisting on choosing a
winner is is creating this distortion
but we're still going to insist that you
have to choose a win i just want to be
clear the problem comes up all the time
when you have these
things
yeah yeah
yeah so the question is like how can we
somehow fix this problem so we're still
picking a better team making the better
forecaster
okay
so
um jens mikowski and friends um
were among um some to identify this
issue
and they came up with a very cool
mechanism that i'll detail later
the event lottery is forecaster or elf
mechanism and it's truthful so it's
truthful in a sense that you optimize
your chance of winning by reporting your
beliefs
and
they also give this accuracy bound where
they pick the best forecaster when the
number of events is um n squared log in
so n is the number of forecasters yeah
and um so it's a very cool paper and
we'll we'll talk about health a little
bit but the kind of the starting point
for us was thinking about
whether this is
a practical bound so
is n squared of log n practical well for
machine learning competitions probably
is fine
and you're saying anything about this
number of
ms and greater than this yeah i mean i
should have written um omega here but
i'll i just didn't want it yeah but yeah
any any number of any number m greater
than greater than order yeah
and if we go back to that march mania
competition there were as it turns out
442 forecasters
but effectively and i'm kind of
converting brackets into binary events
about 2000 events whereas their bound
would need like over a million so does
this have something to do basically with
like looking at all pairs like and
squares enough to see all pairs right
and like
maybe i i don't know we'll talk about
the analysis and we'll see where it
comes from
but you already defined what a best
foreign
yeah so
i'll define it formally in a bit but
for now just think the forecaster whose
beliefs best match the truth
yeah
however
you did call the u.s
or just when you stop settling
oh everyone is predicting all on all the
events
right
yeah probably you could extend this with
your fantasies if some are sleeping
sometimes
okay so the central question basically
is can we can we pick the best
forecaster using fewer events than n
squared again
um it's a good time to note that
pack luring lower bounds well it's not
totally immediate but you can modify
them to give a login or bound
which probably makes sense yeah
talk about the best learner which is the
one that is true it really depends on
the motion of your
yeah so does it depend on the function
it does yeah we'll define accuracy in
terms of the score
and yeah that'll be clear
that's one more thing i'm sorry
um so you're assuming all the
forecasters go all at once
there's no strategizing over here
yeah so inside the competition the
strategizing is like who goes first on
the leaderboard and so on
yeah so
for now actually the model is even more
there's a point about the model that'll
touch on at the very end where we're
assuming immutable beliefs so
you have your beliefs even if you saw
what everyone else forecast you would
not change your release which of course
is not very listed um
but well it turns out you can look at
that
but yeah for the analysis let's just
assume you know what everyone else is
reporting but you still believe what you
believe
okay so the best so we have a gap here
so
n squared log n is what else gets the
best possible is log n um interestingly
the simple max mechanism
um
there's enough concentration at login
for a simple max to also pick the best
with high probability but only if you
ignore the fact that it's not truthful
and actually it's an open question that
i'm not gonna state is trying to figure
out what is actually going on with
simplemax i think that's an interesting
question but it's sort of like it feels
like a first price auction kind of
equilibrium analysis that seems quite
tricky to to pin down
but yeah this fact will come back so
simple max kind of it kind of achieves
the best but only if you ignore the
whole strategizing problem
okay so
so
how close can we get to the log n lower
bound well it turns out if you look at
alph so originally we thought that maybe
we would need to modify elf in some way
to to get this lower bound if it's
possible
but it turns out
you can even improve the analysis of elf
without modifying it to end again
um
but that's tight so we need a new
mechanism and we'll give one i'll i'll
leave some suspense at how close we get
to log in
um and
if there's time i hope there's time even
more relevant to sort of the nominal
name of the workshop i think is this
um
nominal name that was good
um application to online learning
so um
yeah we'll see we'll see if we get there
okay so let me tell you about this elf
mechanism
um
but before i do that we need some we'll
finally fix some notation and i'll
define accuracy in those things
okay so we have
we have events one through t sorry um
one through m
for each event t in each forecaster i
they're going to predict some pit so the
talk will focus on the binary event
setting and you can extend it
um so you know they're going to predict
say the probability of rain
um or sorry that's their belief and
they're going to report something that
might be different rit
and we're going to assume that there's
some ground truth probability of rain
theta t and then yt is the eventual
observed outcome did it did it rain or
not
okay and then
there's a scoring rule that's floating
around
um for the talk it's safe to just think
about quadratic score so given some
report and an outcome
here's um you know one minus squared
error
other things work
right so once you have a score now you
can finally define accuracy so we'll
define accuracy as the
average
expected score of the beliefs
where the outcome is drawn from the true
true distribution
does that make sense
so this is like
this is the true score of your beliefs
normalized across events so that's your
accuracy and so formally what we're
trying to do when i say pick the best
forecaster what i really mean is give me
some epsilon
and i want to pick some forecaster
within epsilon of the best and for most
of the talk i'll suppress the dependence
on epsilon but it's always one over
epsilon squared
okay
um so here's the elf mechanism
so the idea is to kind of
um
right so in each event t you're going to
assign a point to one of the forecasters
so
every round you're going to assign one
point
and you're going to do so randomly
in such a way that's biased by the
scores for that round
and then you're going to pick the
forecaster with the highest number of
points so this is quite similar to
simple max in a way it's just that
you're randomizing in every round first
and then picking the forecaster with the
highest number of points
and the point is that um
right so you're sort of
converting the score to a probability in
a way where if you're just focusing on
round t well
forecaster i maximizes the probability
that they win the point on that round by
maximizing their expected score
so they want to choose the report that
maximizes their expected score
if they're just focused on that round t
the tricky part is to show that it's
truthful
um when they are not just focused on
round t but it turns out um it works
okay so that it is truthful the optimal
strategy is to report your beliefs
and right so
you want to maximize the points in each
round and it's a little subtle to show
that doing so maximizes your chance of
being the highest point getter yeah it's
not completely clear why we are looking
at relationships between two different
forecasters so you have like a bunch of
them and one of them is the best
so i would think that you look at
the loss for each of them and then see
which of them does the best
so why does it help to
you're saying like why am i subtracting
the other forecasters here
right so the the issue basically by the
way this is um this is a form of a
wagering mechanism if you've seen that
before
um yeah the issue is you need to
normalize friends you need the
probabilities to sum to one so it turns
out the right thing to do is subtract so
by so everyone gets a one everyone gets
a uniform probability and then you bias
it
um positively if your score is better
than the average of the rest
negatively otherwise
yeah what is the claim about the
truthfulness of this mechanism
is it truthful if that is bigger than
men look like truthful
because like i mean like in your earlier
example like amigo one
one guy fifty percent two guys nineteen
ten why is the 50 percent guy
gonna put report truthfully in that case
i'm trying to work this out right so
what's the probability that the middle
person wins
well
it's
they get one over m for free and then
one over n times this difference of
scores
and that's still an expectation over yt
great there's no expectation
why these down but when they when they
look at their expected probability of
winning
then they want to maximize their
expected score because i'm paying you in
probability now
so
okay
okay you convert i say
yeah we're converting money to
probability so
right so it works out
all right um
yeah it's a very cool paper i encourage
you to check it out um the analysis is
quite fun
um and so right so they show that it's
truthful and the accuracy bound
just
argues that via the hufting bound if you
have enough events then the point totals
i should have said approximately
proportional to
the the point totals become proportional
to the true accuracies and and that's
good enough
and um
well it turns out
actually hofting is not the right bound
here because
um this
the
so i didn't mention this but the score
the score is always going to be bounded
between zero and one
so the most
right so the most that you could
possibly win
the point the probability the highest
chance you have of winning the point is
to overhead
even if you're really good
and that means this is actually like if
you're counting up how many points i'm
gonna win it's a low variance
situation so you'd be better off using
the bernstein bound and that already as
it turns out means you only need n log n
events
but
this is very close to uniform and this
is kind of if you run this in practice
and play around with this um like in a
classroom setting or something it's very
uniform even in a modest number of of
outcomes
and so that that gives a lower bound and
i think the way to see this is
suppose one forecaster was perfect so
every round they got the point with
probability two over n
and everyone else is terrible they get
the point with probability
a little less than one over n
still
um like by balls and bin's analysis
the chance that some terrible forecaster
will rack up enough points to beat the
best forecaster is still high
um when an m is much lower than n log n
right
okay so
so all of this says that
elf while very cool mechanism it needs
and uh n log n events so naturally
we wonder if you can do better
um how am i doing that time
oh
okay um yes
all right so
yeah go ahead
you know imagine like a basketball game
where it was like
whenever they hit a basket
we actually give them four points with
probability half and zero points of
probability you have that could be like
a way
to you know add a little stochasticity
to a basketball game that's what you're
proposing here rather than pay them the
actual probability you pay them a coin
toss
with that probably you know you put up a
probability value maybe go back to that
slide
rather than pay them the money on the
right which is perfectly compatible just
paying them that right you just pay
everyone that number
you're going to toss a coin
you're saying that somehow this added
stochasticity to the scoring mechanism
generate some truthfulness
yeah so yeah you're exactly right like
it's only because of our fixation in
picking a winner
that we're in this situation at all if
we were happy
watching basketball and having like a
monetary prize i don't know why we're
talking about basketball
i don't think it's a great analogy maybe
but yeah if we're happy with like
forecasting competitions just going out
money at the end instead of selecting a
winner or leaderboard
then there would be no issues
yeah i mean it seems like
the issue with the
issue with the competition you're
proposing is that people are so focused
on the tail
and like what they can get because they
have to become the arguments
yeah they have they're really interested
in what the tail looks like and how like
how how how how much debt how much mass
they can get in their health and they're
not focusing on expected value
expected expected value like the upper
tail the tail of the total more points
that they get yeah yeah right right
if they were just focusing expected
value
which is what you kind of want them to
focus on that's what what the score
making the score rule members assumes is
that they're focusing aspect i was like
well we do kind of pick a winner or
they're not going to focus they're going
to focus on other things other
statistics wouldn't really like that so
how do we kind of force them to stop
caring about the tail because we're
going to like generate a randomization
for them already is that kind of the
idea here
let's see into engineering it's weird
you're just adding extras and stock
acidity to the payoff
the expected value of these payouts are
the same whether you toss the coin or
just pay them that number no you you
make the expected principal winning
yeah it's it's like like if you know the
scoring rules literature when you're
worried about risk preferences
if someone's very risk-averse they won't
be maximizing their expected score but
you can fix that by just giving them a
lot or anywhere okay you'll win a
million dollars with a little bit more
probability
so you convert it to probability that's
that's how i would summarize their trade
what what we're going to do is something
a little more similar to your intuition
okay yeah and um
yeah sorry this is a great discussion i
just have to you know march along
[Laughter]
um so
we tried to be honest we tried a lot of
things um
before arriving at what i'm about to
tell you and um we finally gave up
and just came crawling back to simple
max like simple max
you get this login bound
but you're not truthful like can we work
this out somehow
and
and one one reason that simple max
doesn't work i mean at an intuitive
level is that it's very sensitive so
think back to that example where we had
you know 50 in the middle and then 10
and 90 percent
like as soon as 50 if they if that
middle forecaster raises their report
past 90 percent all of a sudden they go
from a zero percent chance of winning to
a 50 chance so
in machine learning we solve sensitivity
problems like this to stabilize our our
you know selection or whatever with
regularization so
you know maybe we could try something
like that here
so here is the you know follow the
regularized leader
algorithm that you've seen many times
already in the workshop
um we'll be thinking about this in a
batch setting so if there's time at the
end i'll talk about the online learning
setting
problem where the fact that we use ftrl
helps us out a lot
but for now let's just think about this
so
i'm going to choose
a distribution pi over the forecasters
that's going to be the distribution from
which i select the winner
and i'm going to select it like this i'm
going to choose pi like this so
choose pi to maximize
the weight that i put
you know the expected score under pi of
the forecasters but i'm going to you
know penalize with some regularization
so if um
you know if i take this learning
rate you know this parameter eta to
infinity
then i approach just the simple max i
want to put all my weight on the best
forecaster but i want to hedge a little
bit
um
so
if you plug in negative entropy you get
the familiar multiplicative weights
okay so
the question is maybe maybe could this
work enough
um
right so
for a large ada
it works in one sense we only need login
events but because it's because it looks
like simple max but it's not truthful
so what happened what about small eta
um
right so here's the form for
multiplicative weights let's i'll just
focus on multiplicative weights for the
talk
um
right so you you exponentiate eta times
the
the empirical scores of each of the
forecasters and then normalize
but for really small eta
this is roughly proportional to
one plus
beta times the sum of the scores so if
you're trying to maximize your chance of
winning then you should maximize
your expected scores again
so it's somehow
like jake was saying like
for small ada it seems that we're
aligning the incentives again
um where we're just getting you there's
you don't have to worry about the tail
i'm like we're adding enough randomness
that all that doesn't matter just just
worry about your
bias um just worry about
increasing your your score
yeah this is also somehow like
the accident
soft max is like definitely much
smoother for a bunch of reasons right
this is a way to get like truthfulness
out of all sorts of stuff uh and like
privacy out of all sorts of stuff yeah
yeah so this is we originally started
from differential privacy actually and
we're looking at like laplace smoothing
yeah exactly
but um
right so
hey depends on f right
so it will depend a and m will be tied
yeah
okay so let me try to formalize though
what i mean by
this being close to truthful and this is
this is kind of where
where we had to do some thinking so
um
so let's recall dominating strategies so
for two strategies a and b for player i
we say a dominates b if no matter what
other players do a is better for player
i than b
right and so truthfulness just means
that reporting your beliefs is a
dominant strategy
and we're going to find some approximate
truthful notion
which is slightly stronger than
approximate truthfulness that you may
have seen
where reports that are
outside of a gamma ball around your
belief are dominated
um
and it turns out that multiplicative
weights is four eta approximately
truthful
so what that means is you know by by
taking ada to be very small
i can ensure that well i don't really
know what the equilibrium is
um if indeed there is one but
i can safely assume that everyone is
reporting within gamma of their belief
because
otherwise they'd be doing something so
yeah one question
exactly
but we don't like
pih spots
that i select forecaster high
right so um
i think you're getting maybe exactly
this question which is for large ada
we're not truthful but we're highly
selected
we make a definitive choice for small
ada sure we're approximately truthful
but i mean we're close to uniform
so
if what we really care about is choosing
the best forecaster with high
probability that seems not so great but
maybe there's a sweet spot
maybe we can be
truthful enough but also selective
enough
and it turns out that that is indeed the
case
so if epsilon is this
accuracy that i want
choosing eta to be order epsilon
um gives us an epsilon accurate
forecaster with high probability with
log n over epsilon event
which matches the lower bound
yeah
but it is not fair to say
that we match the lower bound because
the lower bound was for the
exact titularity
it's the same it's the same
right so lower bound is the the
probability with which you can choose an
epsilon
i mean like maybe all of them suck right
like you mean the top guy what do you
mean excellent close to the top epsilon
of the best
yeah
um
okay so and also this is an absolute
truth as you were saying earlier
and it's also a truthful an absolute
truthful
yeah
order excellent truthful right right
okay so um
i have some time to show you a bit of
the proof um first i would like to
to quote a great researcher in our field
so um i don't know i don't know how much
you want to see of this but but let's do
it anyway
um okay
so yeah so let's set let's say i think
it's kind of it's cool to see how
how everything can connect maybe um
well tell me if you agree after the talk
okay so again so we're going to take ada
to be order epsilon and m is going to be
order log n over epsilon squared
okay and
the proof proceeds by just kind of
carefully tracking these three
quantities
so
the empirical score of forecaster i
that's what the mechanism actually has
access to and i'm normalizing here by
the number of rounds
and the expected score is sort of the
next thing removed um
you don't see the truth but you know you
can imagine what is the actual expected
score of the reports
and then the thing that you really care
about is the accuracy where instead of
the reports i plug in the beliefs of
that forecaster
right and
by epsilon you know by saying we're
choosing an epsilon accurate forecaster
what i mean is
um you know a forecaster within epsilon
of the best
so let i be the best forecaster and
let's think about trying to upper bound
the probability that we choose any
epsilon bad forecaster
right so we have j is some epsilon bad
forecaster so the differences in the
accuracies is epsilon so i is up here j
is down there
all right so
approximate truthfulness
tells us
that
the difference between these two
quantities is small
so
um i'm
so let me take you through that so right
so we're four eta approximately truthful
which means that the beliefs and the
reports are within four eta
which is order epsilon
and
so we're going to need our score to be
lip sheets so there's some constant here
so i can go from
the the inputs to the outputs which is
the the scores themselves but you know
squared errors two lipschitz so we'll
need that
but you know aside from that you tune
the constants and you can say well um
you know i'm taking ada small enough so
that the the gap between the accuracies
and
the um expected scores of the reports
is epsilon over five say
right and now now can you we can apply
hofting to get some concentration to say
well the
empirical and expected scores are close
enough
and so now we're still left with an
order epsilon gap between the empirical
scores
so good so we we have
we have that if we have an epsilon bad
forecaster
we know that there is an empirical gap
with high probability
of order epsilon between the
the scores that we see
so the only thing left then is to
convert that into a multiplicative
gap so i'm picking forecaster high with
much more probability than j and this
part is probably familiar if you've seen
some analysis of multiplicative weights
um so you rewrite
you rewrite the pi i's i'm rewriting it
in terms of these empirical scores and
i'm multiplying by m because i
normalized
right so we can ask all right so under
under this rule how much
more likely are we to pick i than j
so the normalization
cancels out and now
i get this you know this additive gap of
order epsilon i'm going to convert to a
multiplicative gap
and now all right so recall that eight
is order epsilon
and i'm going to take m to be
order log n over delta over epsilon
squared
and so all the constants i'm just
ignoring all the constants so
um but right so that i have an epsilon
squared times m here
right so i'm just left with
uh n over delta so i have like an
order n over delta a multiplicative gap
and now i'm good to go so if i look at
the probability of choosing a bad
forecaster now that's bounded by delta
over n but they're at most n bad
forecasters
so the probability i choose any bad
forecasters is delta
questions yeah
delta is different than epsilon so delta
delta think of it as parameterizing the
high probability bound
whereas epsilon is is the accuracy
yeah
like the best way to apply this thing
it's like if you're selling
that all of the scores
and in that case you can set if you set
up salon about the way like the top
square to the time before pastors are
all
your guarantees says the top scorer then
four customers
if you're lucky and all the scores look
kind of easily spread out they're
roughly between zero right
so then like this box where
uh the forecasters like are pretty
likely to
like like any one of them so this
there was an epsilon as well but i'll
suppress it
yeah and
um part of the reason is we didn't quite
get the epsilon squared for the lower
bound i think but the upper bound that
we get is n log n over epsilon squared
so epsilon still
would you say between the initial
dependence
yeah so all these accuracy bounds are
stated as what is the problem like
how many events do i need so that i take
an epsilon accurate forecast or with my
problem
so that yeah
it's been there all along
yeah any other questions
next up is online learning so
yeah
so this book don't have any
republicans
oh
um yeah so what do we need we need um
i think we need a strong concavity
assumption
and boundedness and lupus
yeah i think like boundedness is a very
interesting question that gets into some
discussion we had during tim's talk
about what happens with a log score one
round can kind of seal the fate so i
think it's quite tricky there
yeah it does seem like the other ones
are necessary too
yeah this matches where you get out of
noisy max right
yeah like
noisy max
epsilon
take
ah so that's a different truthfulness
yeah so that truthfulness that absolute
truthfulness or that approximate
truthfulness is like
i'm not too unhappy
but
um other deviations
and this is saying um
right this is saying that i actually
would be silly to report something
outside of
yeah so we um
versus
the other thing right sorry so this is a
question of like whether yeah
yeah it's like this is in the inputs to
the utility and
trustfulness the other truthfulness is
sort of like i'm i'm sort of okay
reporting my
right in fact you're okay with whatever
in that setting right here with whatever
yeah so yeah we needed something
stronger because um
yeah we needed to be able to control
the reports to make sure that we're
picking a good forecaster yeah
which would be wouldn't it make it
easier at all to pick the best degree
with the best accuracy if you didn't
have the approximate truthfulness
constraint
or it would be just as hard
i think the challenge is understanding
the equilibrium
but
and like i said it may be that simple
max works but
everyone's like thrashing around trying
to best respond but somehow
the best player in that complicated game
is still the best forecaster
so that might be true but you'd have to
figure out what people are doing
yeah
so this might be a terrible question so
i'm going to promise with that what if
you choose the second best like you you
you remove the max which is the second
best like it's like a price auction type
thing without
work
well something like i will try to be one
of the best but not the best yeah yeah
that's a very interesting question
because it's just like that's what we do
in auctions
yeah
but you don't select this you select the
first best
without money but actually we have some
money the points are the money that we
give to
each other so they see also here there
are no points for around thousand hours
mechanism i should see like that the
money that the price
of the mechanism
and the prices in the mechanism means
the points that they eat
is not correct
as an analysis or it is a mechanism
without money
i i think it's best to think of it as a
mechanism without money where you know
you're selecting a winner
okay so
maybe we'll leave the other questions on
that for the end because i feel morally
obligated to tell you about the online
stuff
okay so this is going to be pretty quick
actually um
um punchline
this works in online learning as well
okay
um
so
let me let me tell you a bit i think
it's
it might be good to take a deep breath
and let go of the forecasting setting
because um otherwise this might be
confusing so now we're in a completely
different setting um
i didn't hear many deep breaths but i'm
assuming you're you're working on that
um
right so now now we're in the classic
let's think about the classic online
learning settings we have a bunch of
rounds in each round you have some
experts
and they're giving you advice
pit these are the same pit so the
classic setting we're assuming these are
the beliefs
and the algorithm let's say is going to
choose an expert at each round and by
choosing expert that means predict
whatever they said
and they do so with some probability the
algorithm does so with some probability
and the algorithm is trying to perform
not much worse than the best expert
measured in terms of regret
okay in the strategic setting we imagine
that now the experts can lie so they
have some beliefs but maybe they report
something else
and why would they do that well they're
trying to maximize their chance of being
chosen
and you could think of this as
like
so there's there's some work looking at
the myopic case
um where
in each round the experts are just
trying to maximize their chance of being
chosen the next round
um
but more generally so that's you know
not a great model in in some ways
we really like you know forward-looking
agents that maybe are trying to maximize
the total number of times they're chosen
so anything like that will basically
work here um so i'm not going to specify
that but
um so in some sense trying to maximize
their chance of being chosen and you can
you can play around with what exactly
they're trying to maximize
and now
so the gal
the interesting thing is here we're
stating this as the algorithm has the
same goal though
trying to perform well
um compared to the best expert but here
importantly we're we want to compare to
the best experts beliefs
not whatever they said to like game
our learning algorithm
we want to have a guarantee that says we
we did well compared to the best
forecaster best expert in the same sense
that i've been describing
okay and so
while while this
there are some interesting um
results for the myopic case it's been
open to find such an algorithm for the
general case and it turns out the same
analysis kind of gives you that so we
can achieve routine regret even in the
presence of strategic experts
and the proof is
um i think i can sketch the proof from
three lines
um basically
so you start with the standard regret
guarantees for fdrl so fdrl says well if
you set the learning rate like one over
square root t then we get root t regret
but with respect to the reports right so
it's a worst case guarant guarantee so
no matter what the reports are no matter
what the outcomes are i get rooty regret
and now approximate truthfulness kicks
in so we can say well
actually the reports
have to be within order eta of the
beliefs so that's one over root t
so
how much do we lose by the fact that the
reports were not the same as their
beliefs
well in each round we pick up
a one over t
uh sorry one over root t so overall the
extra regret from all that is routine
online learning the adversary does what
so the adversary is choosing the
outcomes okay
like literary
yeah i mean you can think of yeah
this will hold for all beliefs
right
well adversary choosing the outcome it
doesn't feel like there's an underlying
probability yeah yeah sorry so yeah so
sorry yeah i think i misspoke so by best
expert i i mean um
using like
the normal regret guarantee but plugging
in the pits so it's the empirical the
empirical best in hindsight yeah we just
didn't take a deep enough breath because
thinking
that like the outcomes are chosen by uh
some that there should be something
going on here like there actually is a
theta t that we would like to know
asking people to think about it but when
you go to expert setting you should
really have to forget that there isn't
an underlying probability
right
yeah it's still adversarial
as if they were in the most part pages
or
yeah it does work for my outfit
um
sorry
it works yeah so the the formal
statement is that
any
positive linear combination of the pits
so if i'm
an expert i and i care my my utility is
some positive linear combination of the
pi ids sorry
so that the chances of being chosen on
each round then any of those will work
so my optic would be like this weird
thing where
on round t i only care about
pi i t plus one but that also is okay so
myopic is something like markovian or uh
it just means that um on round t experts
only try to maximize their chance of
being chosen on round two
then they you know they black out forget
everything that happened and do the same
thing
yeah
so should i be thinking of
multiplicative weights as the mechanism
yeah
so are there other applications besides
these forecasting competitions where you
might use a multiplicative weights
uh mechanism and then get this kind of
same result that you can
be strategic
i'm not quite sure
somewhat generic i don't know i'm just
trying to think there are other
applications where you might be able to
use this kind of same recipe if your
point is that it is only for multiple
weight updates or it is for anything
well maybe there are other mechanisms
inside the forecasting environment where
that might be okay maybe not yeah i mean
like the online learning setting is in
some sense an example where
it feels like a very different setting
like it's adversarial it's not
it's not like a forecasting competition
but yet
the approximate truthfulness of the
mechanism
um
is still still but it seems like there
might be other settings where you want
that same like you want to be
approximately you could potentially be
strategic in an online learning setting
but it's really nice to have the
approximate truthfulness of that sort of
oh yeah
yeah i mean it seems like it seems like
a nice tool maybe for other settings i
don't know
okay let me um
let me wrap up
i guess i don't understand how it's an
adversarial setting it's how do i
understand
the agent's strategies if they don't
if the outcome is just
chosen think it's adversarial for the
lurker
yeah yeah exactly so i think the agents
still have beliefs
right
so the
experts have probabilistic beliefs
no it doesn't even have to be it's just
like an assumption about their
rationality so expert eye thinks that
the outcome is drawn from
you know vit and so they're going to be
best response you know trying to
maximize their chance of being chosen
under that and your regret's going to be
with respect to the best expert as
though they were not the age procedure
correct
yeah
yeah so i think that's a great example
of
um something that
like that's a positive linear
combination of
the pi so like i want
my utility is like
like beta times my probability of being
selected tomorrow plus beta squared
times the next one that'll be fine
okay
um
so this is the last slide um
so what we we showed so in competitions
and forecasting competitions
um we get better event complexity so elf
already gets an login
event so it can pick the
pick at best forecaster with n log n
events
but curiously um
multiplicative weights
and other fdrl algorithms achieve the
optimal bound of login
and in online learning we get rootie
regret even in the presence of strategic
experts so i think there are kind of two
interesting takeaways the first
is maybe kaggle should add some
regularization and i'm kind of
um jake knows well how kaggle deals with
um helpful suggestions so i'm like we've
tried to get kaggle to implement things
in the past um so i'm i'm trying to
make my case very solidly so there's
some there's some things that i think we
need to work out but i'm kind of hoping
that you know maybe we can try this in
some real competitions
um
and i think you know but
for this audience maybe a more
interesting observation is that
right often in algorithmic economics and
algorithmic game theory we ask what is
the cost of strategic behavior in
various settings like price of anarchy
kind of statements and
really in these two settings forecasting
competitions online learning we're
somehow able to match
the best non-strategic
bounds up to constants
even when there's strategic behavior
going on
and i would say i don't like i don't
understand this
to the extent that satisfies me like i
think there's something going on here
that would be interesting to dive into
further and i'll just end with
a couple extensions and open questions
so
i mentioned that you know
founded scoring rules with better lip
shits and have some curvature are fine
we extended beyond binary outcomes there
are other regularizers that work um
and um here's an interesting one so
there's there's something
that's not quite satisfying about this
immutable belief model and that's that
every forecaster thinks that they're the
best
if you think about like what's implied
by
everyone has their own beliefs
and no matter what other people say
they're sticking to their beliefs
then that means that they believe their
expected score is going to be higher
than everyone else's and that's like a
really weird
feature of the model and you'd really
like to be able to express things like i
believe that jake is a better forecaster
than i am
and to do that you have to allow
um the reports of other agents to
correlate with the truth but it turns
out that
everything continues to hold if you have
a more realistic model like that
um and i think
two interesting open questions it's not
clear whether there is an exactly
truthful mechanism that achieves the
login bound so approximate truthfulness
we would argue is pretty good
um
but you know you really like an exactly
truthful mechanism so it's not clear
yeah that's a great open question
and um finally
throughout all this work in this area
we've assumed that events
are independent of each other
but
you
intuitively you should be able to
tolerate some correlation between events
and you would like the bounds to degrade
in like the number of bits of randomness
in the total number of events right so
if they're all perfectly core related
well it's just like there's one event so
there's not much you can do but if
there's enough randomness
then hopefully
um this can extend
okay
thanks
[Applause]
thank you ralph
questions
yes but more questions
uh i really like your second point um
and i was just curious you know so we
have a lot of
you know we know a lot of algorithms or
like um i guess indirect mechanisms
like i'm thinking something like an
ascending auctions where you have
guarantees that you're going to convert
to a certain thing
uh maybe an ascending action is not a
good uh like example but like let's take
something like fictitious play
like a dynamic that's decentralized and
people maybe actually might be strategic
at each round or something they might
lie so that they end up
in a better spot like assuming that
their adversary also plays the same
dynamic like using this approach do you
think that you could like guarantee in
some way
that you will converge to i don't know a
close
like uh bowl of like
the actual spot that you were supposed
to converge to and if that makes sense
like here you're saying
that my experts can lie to me and i'm
still
guaranteeing a certain optimality
uh like do you think you can extend this
approach to a more to other stuff like
some auctions where we don't like dine
up some auctions that are ascending or
we don't think of like
uh some diet some like incentives but
that are guaranteed to convert to a
certain like competitor something like
that could you guarantee that we're
going to converge like an epsilon com
like competitive equilibrium by taking
this approach yeah that's a great
question so i think i i'm not really an
expert in auctions but
i would say that
the general solution concept
such as you can call it that of just
trying to say that
okay whatever people do they're at least
not doing this
might be a useful tool in other settings
like that when you're trying to
get some approximation guarantee about
the behavior in some complicated action
um
it does seem
like we needed a lot of
curvature assumptions that a line that
lined up um which fortunately worked out
so we needed the regularizers to have
like lipschitz hessians and things like
that so we had to carefully control the
smoothness
to show that um to show the approximate
truthfulness that was like the technical
meat of the paper actually
um
so
i'm not sure
whether you could show such a thing in
auctions like
maybe maybe
you would not have enough continuity or
something
i'm thinking maybe like instead of like
a strategic experts if it was like
kind of more online comics optimization
setting but where like your parameters
can be chosen
adversarially by strategic like
strategic
i don't know adversaries
could you obtain similar results
i'm not sure okay
and more questions
oh hello okay yeah it's kind of
complicated well a simple question but
you get it
so there might be a difference uh so if
i understand correctly like if you go
myopic versus uh
like all the way until the end like this
will give you different strategies right
otherwise like
so like yeah and then like what what
happens if we're in like in any time
situation where we like so different
strategies like
the experts will do different things uh
i guess the payoffs should be different
otherwise like the myopic thing was also
good for
the uh i don't know what you call it but
until the end yeah yeah the more general
so then like in an anytime setting like
have you thought about
how
both the learning algorithm and the
experts should think about uh
things right when they don't know like
what the last round is
oh yeah
like you know my learning really can do
that so
yeah my general sense is
so this is not a well-founded statement
but my hope slash guess is that
everything could extend to the unknown
horizon setting
like i don't think we're doing anything
it's complicated enough that the
standard tricks
wouldn't work but it might take some
effort
um but
but you mean like on the behavior of the
yeah i guess one thing that could
be complicated is
like
yeah it's a good question yeah
yeah so i guess
where you could go wrong is like say you
set data to be dk and like one over root
t
the
the
the forecasters the experts
knew more about the horizon than you did
and um
you know somehow that wasn't the right
data to set at the beginning it's like a
guessing double should probably get
should be okay but
yeah that's a good question
very interesting experiencing our work
actually i have a question about the
moderator of rationality
so here somehow you assume that the the
agents
uh always be within some some range of
their true valuation right or their
honest beliefs like within that epsilon
interval but maybe if i was a kegel
participant and i knew somehow that
kegel was somewhat like regularizing
maybe i have an incentive and i don't
it's not clear to me how i can solve
this problem to compute the epsilon and
i could be tempted to learn myself so a
lot of time i'm i'm kind of like
deviating from my two beliefs just
exploring right
could i create is that is that a
meaningful model
do you think or
yeah so i guess two responses one is
probably kaggle should post their
mechanism
everyone would be upset if they didn't
so then you would know like
okay and they could post their guarantee
like but
famous scientists have shown
that you should not deviate by more than
the scammer or something like that are
you going to send some good cool
pictures
but also
um
yeah i would say that
like you wouldn't have a lot of feedback
to learn anyway
unless you're participating in many
competitions or something
right because you're only
the is only reveal at the end of the
competition
are you thinking maybe about the online
learning setting where there's some
feedback every round yeah i was thinking
about the online learning setting but
i'm saying like
what would be the cost for your
mechanism even if
18 each agent lies exactly once
you know
oh like like they lie by a lot but only
a few times
yeah right because it doesn't really
affect me like it's a low risk for me
but maybe it could be like a big risk
for the for the mechanism
just to be sure your model is i will not
be very rational but
in playing the game i would try just to
compete in copy and just think a little
bit
uh yeah okay so like system one
okay
i think it should be okay but there you
go and on that note let's uh thank rock
again
[Applause]